hogwarts legacy is being developed by  avalanche software  nope not the just cause devs the cars 3  devs in fact this will be the longest  avalanche has worked on a single title  given that cars 3 released all the way  back in 2017. avalanche has confirmed  the game will appear on pc ps4 ps5 xbox  one as well as the xbox series s and x  wb is publishing the game under the port  key games label which is a label  specifically created for the wizarding  world of harry potter we also know  they're using the unreal engine for the  project and although information has  been scarce since the initial trailer  warner media ceo jason keller tweeted  out four concept images back in april of  2021 which showed the house crests a  baby dragon a garden gnome and two grap  horns in a small enclosure on what  appear to be the hogwarts grounds also  one of the avalanche devs who works on  the sound design for the game did an  interview in may of 2021 where he  answered some questions about the game